it's a new week and that means new
releases and this week kojima's vision
comes to fruition with metal gear solid
5 the phantom pain ground zeroes
probably wet your appetite but it's
small taste of your options in phantom
pains you get lots of tools at your
disposal from upgrades in your
prosthetic arm to numerous weapons and
even a cute little puppy Peter Brown
gave the game a ten out of ten saying
there's never been a game in the series
of such depth as its gameplay or so much
volume in content the best elements from
the past games are here and the new
open-world gameplay adds more to love on
top the phantom pain may be a contender
for one of the best action games ever
made but it's undoubtedly the best metal
gear game there is your mission starts
on the first
and if this week wasn't cool enough we
also get the vehicular combat open-world
desert of destruction with Mad Max Max's
journey to the plains silence takes an
unexpected turn when a group of war boys
run him off the road steal his clothes
supplies weapons his car just leaving
him to rot in the Sun traversing the
wasteland in search of his prized
interceptor Max meets the hunchbacked
mechanic named chumbucket and he's
hell-bent on crafting the perfect
vehicle the magnum opus the to form an
unlikely partnership and set out in
search of food water allies upgrades and
redemption in a world devoid of sanity
it's gonna be murderous fun and I expect
you to witness we're going to Valhalla
on the first
well things are getting a little violent
aren't they let's take a turn for the Q
with the action-adventure sandbox game
Disney infinity 3.0 vents star wars
episode to attack of the clones Anakin
Skywalker and ahsoka tano discovered a
reactivated droid factory the two Jedi
decide to find out who's the mastermind
behind the newly minted droid army
you're gonna cross paths with a lot of
known characters like General Grievous
Jabba the Hutt Padme and Darth Maul and
you get to travel to planets that you
might remember like Tatooine and it's
all going down within the Disney
infinity universe so you know it's gonna
be light-hearted fun you're my only hope
obi-wan on the 30th just a few games to
remind you about dangan ronpa another
episode ultra despair girls comes to PS
Vita on the first the beautiful role
playing strategy board game are mellow
pops out early access and on the full
release on pc ps4 and mobile that's on
the first zombie Vikings hits ps4 on the
first and the same goes to grow home and
dear God hits xbox one on the first and
it's free to play if you got goals for a
limited time finally Bethesda is
releasing the Imperial City first major
dlc for ESO Tamriel unlimited anyone who
has an active ESO plus subscription gets
the extra content for free or
alternatively it's gonna cost you
twenty-five hundred crowns via the
in-game store you're getting six new
Imperial districts with additional
dungeons quests enemies characters a new
currency for veteran ranked 16 weapons
and an armory of other new weapons all
that hot DLC releases on the 31st for
further details visit gamespot com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and they're subject to change
see you next week